Lucia: 就是做可行性研究报告
Lucia: Is to do a feasibility study report
Lucia: 其中包括我们的预算
Lucia: Which includes our budget
Alice: 我们的预算是不是告急了
Alice: Is our budget running low?
Lucia: 是不是告急了
Lucia: Is it running low?
Jake: 每人500吧
Jake: 500 each
Tasha: 什么东西每人500
Tasha: 500 each for what?
Jake: 每人500的那个房间对吧
Jake: 500 each for the room, right?
Alice: 啊不是我说我说我们总体的
Alice: Ah no, I mean, I mean our overall budget
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake: 总体我们我们还花什么钱吗
Jake: Overall, what else are we spending money on?
Katrina: 我们其实主要就吃吃喝喝花了点钱
Katrina: Mostly, we've just spent money on food and drinks
Lucia: 我们恩格尔系数超高
Lucia: Our Engel coefficient is very high
Katrina: 哈哈哈确实
Katrina: Hahaha, true
Jake: 全是生存成本这个没办法
Jake: It's all living costs, can't be helped
Lucia: 人是铁饭是钢嘛
Lucia: People need food to live
Jake: 对这个
Jake: Yes, this
Lucia: 对哈哈
Lucia: Yes, haha
Lucia:  这个
Lucia: This
Tasha: 我看附近租的好多都是哈利波特的啊
Tasha: I see a lot of the rentals nearby are Harry Potter ones
Katrina: 这环球
Katrina: This Universal Studios
Katrina: 就我们附近的一个公园哎
Katrina: There's a park near us, right?
Katrina: 就是去看大爷遛弯
Katrina: Just go watch the old guys walking around
Jake: 就这些都是奢侈品项目里边的奢侈品
Jake: All these are luxuries within the luxury projects
Jake: 这些都是
Jake: All these are
Katrina: 昨天30度今天20度
Katrina: Yesterday was 30 degrees, today it's 20
Katrina: 这日子没
Katrina: This weather is crazy
Katrina: 嗯北京特别大
Katrina: Yeah, Beijing is really huge.
Lucia: 牛仔裤或者假的
Lucia: Jeans or maybe fake ones.
Lucia: 当然现在关键是大家好像没有
Lucia: But the main issue now is that it seems like no one has...
Lucia: 就是就是我们自己的衣服凑
Lucia: Like, we can't gather our own clothes.
Lucia: 凑不出来
Lucia: Can't pull it together.
Lucia: 风格统一的一套否则的话也就
Lucia: We need a set with a unified style, otherwise...
Lucia: 是用自己的衣服也行
Lucia: We could just use our own clothes.
Lucia: 像我们之前上课的时候
Lucia: Like when we had classes before.
Lucia: 就最后汇报表演
Lucia: For the final performance.
Lucia: 就是我们老师就是挑的那种
Lucia: Our teacher would choose those...
Lucia: 就是大概三四十块钱的那种小上衣
Lucia: Around 30-40 yuan tops.
Lucia: 然后底下一个五六十的那种裤子
Lucia: And pants that are about 50-60 yuan.
Lucia: 只不过他可能没有打过风格
Lucia: They might not fit the style.
Lucia: 就那种偏稍微休闲一点的风格
Lucia: A bit more casual style.
Tasha: 永乐店
Tasha: Yongledian.
Tasha: 不知道呀搜一搜
Tasha: No idea, let's search it up.
Jake: 高德在国内是很常用吗
Jake: Is Gaode commonly used in China?
Jake: 嗯就是比百度地图要好
Jake: Hmm, it's better than Baidu Maps.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 我觉得比百度好用
Katrina: I think it's better than Baidu.
Katrina: 它的界面流程上
Katrina: Its interface is more fluid.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 好远呢
Tasha: It's pretty far.
Jake: 在哪好远多远
Jake: Where is it, how far?
Katrina: 多远
Katrina: How far?
Jake: 18公里算了
Jake: 18 kilometers, forget it.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 真郊区
Katrina: Really outskirts.
Jake: 通州还要再开
Jake: We'll still need to drive in Tongzhou.
Jake: 18公里
Jake: 18 kilometers.
Katrina: 对通州还要开18公里
Katrina: Yeah, another 18 kilometers in Tongzhou.
Jake: 走吃饺子吧
Jake: Let's go eat dumplings.
Jake: 走吧吃饺子
Jake: Yeah, let's go eat dumplings.
Katrina: 走吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Alice: 需要拼不对
Alice: Need to get it right.
Alice: 需要醋那个
Alice: Need vinegar for it.
Jake: 那哎
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 要醋要带
Jake: Don't forget the vinegar.
Jake: 带上去带上去
Jake: Bring it along.
Alice: 哦那什么时候录
Alice: Oh, when are we recording?
Alice: 哎不对导数据呢
Alice: Oh wait, exporting data.
Katrina: 对今天是
Katrina: Yeah, today is...
Alice: 吃完OK哎呀
Alice: Finish eating, okay, oh no!
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Jake: 吃饺子
Jake: Eating dumplings.
Katrina: 当然是点的外卖呀
Katrina: Of course, we ordered takeout.
Katrina: 我们还包饺子
Katrina: We're also making dumplings.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 我们包个饺子吧
Jake: Let's make some dumplings.
Alice: 哈哈哈真的吗
Alice: Hahaha, really?
Jake: 不不不这个太麻烦了
Jake: No, no, no, that's too much trouble.
Jake: 我们没有什么精力包饺子
Jake: We don't have the energy to make dumplings.
Katrina: 我们很
Katrina: We're very...
Katrina: 我们在完成最后一天的任务已经够呛
Katrina: We're already struggling to complete the last day's tasks.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 对时间还挺紧的
Jake: Yeah, time is pretty tight.
Katrina: 还要装饰房间还要排舞
Katrina: We still need to decorate the room and rehearse the dance.
Katrina: 其实还蛮多事的
Katrina: There's actually a lot to do.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 有人一起上楼吗
Alice: Is anyone going upstairs?
Katrina: 一起上楼吗有有有
Katrina: Going upstairs? Yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 嚯这这一身哈利波特吗
Jake: Whoa, are you dressed as Harry Potter?
Katrina: 啥
Katrina: What?
Alice: 真的吗已经换装了
Alice: Really? Already changed?
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Katrina: 谁啊
Katrina: Who?
Alice: 嗯来了一个
Alice: Yep, someone came.
Jake: 我刚刚远远一看
Jake: I just saw from afar.
Jake: 我觉得这服装到底啥意思啊
Jake: I was wondering what the outfit meant.
Jake: 这个啊
Jake: This one.
Katrina: 哦好了好了
Katrina: Oh, okay, okay.
Katrina: 我以为你说来了谁
Katrina: I thought you meant who came.
Jake: 刚刚他是
Jake: Just now he was...
Jake: 就是过来的时候他的那个粉色是
Jake: When he came over, the pink part was...
Jake: 大概到一半就是黑的
Jake: About halfway it was black.
Jake: 粉的就是就你这个服装很好看
Jake: The pink part, this outfit looks really good.
Jake: 走吃饭去
Jake: Let's go eat.
Jake: 吃饺子去
Jake: Let's eat dumplings.
Katrina: 走吧上楼去拿瓶醋吧
Katrina: Let's go upstairs and grab a bottle of vinegar.
Jake: 你们上楼收拾收拾
Jake: You guys go upstairs and tidy up.
Jake: 然后把这边
Jake: And then over here...
Jake: 空下来我就
Jake: Once this is empty, I'll...
Katrina: 没打扫卫生
Katrina: Didn't clean up.
Jake: 哦是什么
Jake: Oh, what is it?
Jake: 我我我就测一个内参
Jake: I'll measure an internal reference.
Jake: 我测个外参
Jake: I'll measure an external reference.
Katrina: 没人打扫
Katrina: Nobody cleaned up.
Katrina: 想打扫就打扫
Katrina: If you want to clean, then clean.
Katrina: 我今天早上起来洗了个碗
Katrina: I washed a dish this morning.
Katrina: 当然了这么多人
Katrina: Of course, with so many people...
Katrina: 拿个
Katrina: Take one...
Katrina: 没有啊想干就干不想干
Katrina: No, if you want to do it, do it. If not...
Katrina: 我们的作息也非常的一致
Katrina: Our schedules are very consistent.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 就我们上午11点开始
Katrina: We start at 11 AM.
Katrina: 要吃什么也很随便
Katrina: What we eat is also very casual.
Katrina: 大家都很好相处
Katrina: Everyone gets along well.
Katrina: 所以不是我一个人的问题
Katrina: So it's not just my problem.
Katrina: 是当代年轻人都是这样的
Katrina: It's how young people are these days.
Katrina: 所以我们就不要住一起
Katrina: So we shouldn't live together.
Katrina: 上楼吃饭
Katrina: Let's go upstairs to eat.
Katrina: 楼下的桌子满了呀
Katrina: The tables downstairs are full.
Katrina: 如何在家自制
Katrina: How to make it at home...
Katrina: 对啊楼上楼下户型都一样
Katrina: Yeah, the layout is the same upstairs and downstairs.
Katrina: 一个客厅再见
Katrina: One living room, see you.
Katrina: 我的拖鞋
Katrina: My slippers...
Katrina: 怎么了每个人都有一双这个拖鞋
Katrina: What's wrong? Everyone has a pair of these slippers.
Katrina: 说什么呢
Katrina: What are you talking about?
Katrina: 不跟你说了拜拜
Katrina: Not talking to you anymore, bye.
Katrina: 什么呀谢谢谢谢
Katrina: What? Thank you, thank you.
Katrina: 上次上次帮帮他给女朋友挑礼物来着
Katrina: Last time, I helped him pick a gift for his girlfriend.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 然后他给我带了点东西感谢
Katrina: And then he brought me something as a thank you.
Katrina: 刚刚那是工作人员
Katrina: That was a staff member just now.
Katrina: 就是北邮的一个学生
Katrina: 我靠绝世好男人啊
Katrina: Wow, what a perfect man.
Katrina: 我跟你说
Katrina: Let me tell you...
Katrina: 女朋友发了八九个链接全买
Katrina: His girlfriend sent him eight or nine links, and he bought them all.
Katrina: 就刚刚那个男生
Katrina: Just that guy earlier.
Katrina: 不接因为他女朋友给他买
Katrina: He didn’t answer because his girlfriend bought it for him.
Katrina: 发了一套那个化妆品的链接
Katrina: I sent a link to a set of makeup products.
Katrina: 我以为他要挑一个呢
Katrina: I thought he would choose one.
Katrina: 结果人家全买
Katrina: But he bought the whole set.
Katrina: 我靠这几个都是好男人
Katrina: Wow, these guys are all great men.
Katrina: 我跟你说这几个
Katrina: Let me tell you about these guys.
Katrina: 我们一共4男两个啊
Katrina: There are four of them, two of us.
Katrina: 4女两男嘛
Katrina: Four girls, two guys.
Katrina: 然后一个男生就是我们那个
Katrina: One of the guys is our team leader.
Katrina: 负责人然后还有一个男生
Katrina: The other guy is from the northeast.
Katrina: 就是东北那个
Katrina: And his phone wallpaper is his girlfriend.
Katrina: 嗯那壁手机壁纸都是女朋友
Katrina: He always shows me videos of him and his girlfriend.
Katrina: 然后老给我看他跟他女朋友视频
Katrina: You know what, can't he stop rubbing it in?
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: Seriously.
Katrina: 不是你能别刺激我吗
Katrina: Can you not rub it in?
Katrina: 然后还有两个工作人员是北欧的
Katrina: And then there are two staff members from Northern Europe.
Katrina: 然后他们就是过来帮忙的
Katrina: They came to help out.
Katrina: 因为他俩要出国
Katrina: Because they're going abroad.
Katrina: 所以就过来刷一点实验室的经历
Katrina: So they're getting some lab experience.
Katrina: 然后呢一个也有女朋友
Katrina: And one of them has a girlfriend too.
Katrina: 一个是北京的
Katrina: One is from Beijing.
Katrina: 然后刚刚那个是南京的
Katrina: The other one is from Nanjing.
Katrina: 然后他上次他女朋友给他发那个链接
Katrina: Last time, his girlfriend sent him a link.
Katrina: 他不知道去哪买
Katrina: He didn't know where to buy it.
Katrina: 就是比较正规啊
Katrina: He wanted something legit and cheaper.
Katrina: 省钱一点
Katrina: Since I know about this stuff,
Katrina: 然后我不是比较懂吗
Katrina: I gave him a recommendation.
Katrina: 然后我就给他介绍
Katrina: And he asked how he could thank me.
Katrina: 然后他就说怎么感谢我
Katrina: I told him no need to thank me.
Katrina: 我说不用感谢我啊
Katrina: Haha, then he bought me some
Katrina: 哈哈然后然后他就给我买了一点
Katrina: cultural and creative products.
Katrina: 文创
Katrina: All these guys are great.
Katrina: 全是好男人全是
Katrina: They're all great men.
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 不是应该要多谈几个
Katrina: Shouldn't you date a few more people?
Katrina: 多谈几个就知道哪个好哪个坏
Katrina: If you date more, you'll know who's good and who's bad.
Katrina: 这是冰箱贴
Katrina: This is a fridge magnet.
Katrina: 到时贴我们冰箱吧
Katrina: Let's stick it on our fridge.
Katrina: 狂弹弹BUG
Katrina: Just fixing bugs like crazy.
Katrina: 拜拜不跟你说了
Katrina: Bye, talk to you later.
Katrina: 噔噔噔噔噔
Katrina: Dun dun dun dun dun.
Katrina: 他们还不上来吗
Katrina: Aren't they coming up?
Katrina: 这是啥呀
Katrina: What is this?
Alice: 啊腊八蒜哦
Alice: Ah, it's Laba garlic.
Shure:  吃饺子
Shure: Eat it with dumplings.
Katrina: 我们那没有见过这个耶
Katrina: We don't have this where I'm from.
Shure:  这是什么腊八蒜
Shure: What is this Laba garlic?
Katrina: 北方的啊
Katrina: It's a northern thing, right?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 每天都能给我一点小小的南北方差异
Katrina: Every day I get a little taste of the differences between the north and south.
Katrina: 震撼
Katrina: Shocking.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 啊啊
Katrina: Ah ah.
Shure:  你刚才在哼什么
Shure: What were you humming just now?
Katrina: 哎我刚哼的这首歌叫什么来着
Katrina: Hey, what was the name of that song I was humming?
Shure:  你哼的啥
Shure: What were you humming?
Shure:  你再哼一遍
Shure: Hum it again.
Katrina: 忘了
Katrina: I forgot.
Katrina: 7秒钟的记忆
Katrina: I have a 7-second memory.
Katrina: 哒哒哒哒哒啊
Katrina: Da da da da da ah.
Katrina: 美丽的诗
Katrina: Beautiful poetry.
Katrina: 告五人的
Katrina: It's by Accuse Five.
Katrina: 是告五人的
Katrina: 我给你找找啊
Katrina: I'll find it for you.
Shure:  没有这个印象
Shure: No recollection of it.
Katrina: 好像是给男方的
Katrina: I think it's for the guy.
Katrina: 你一封信
Katrina: Your letter.
Katrina: 是
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina: 就是这首歌
Katrina: This is the song.
Shure:  霉霉发新专了
Shure: Taylor released a new album.
其他人：你们发新专了
Others: You guys released a new album?
其他人：快听
Others: Listen quickly.
Shure:  已经不是霉粉了
Shure: I'm not a Swiftie anymore.
其他人：傻逼
Others: Idiot.
Shure:  那你说你上一张专辑你你最爱听
Shure: Then which song from her last album did you love the most?
其他人：上一张专辑一首没听
Others: Didn't listen to a single song from the last album.
Katrina: 哈哈哈什么东西
Katrina: Hahaha, what?
Shure:  哈哈哈什么东西
Shure: Hahaha, what?
Shure:  你看这种又当又立这种
Shure: Look at this hypocritical behavior.
其他人：这种不能从现在开始回归吗
Others: Can't they start liking her again now?
其他人：不喜欢创造专辑
Others: Don't like creating albums.
倒点醋
Pour some vinegar
其他人：卧槽我跟你说
Others: Whoa, let me tell you
其他人：我演唱会的时候放到创造专辑的时候
Others: During my concert, when I was making my album
其他人：我就在那休息了
Others: I just took a break there
Shure:  你演唱会你不是把票卖了吗
Shure: Didn't you sell your tickets for the concert?
Katrina: 这是啥
Katrina: What's this?
Shure:  啊嗨
Shure: Ah, hi
Katrina: what's this
Katrina: What's this?
Shure:  你摸到霉霉大腿了吗
Shure: Did you touch Taylor Swift's thigh?
陌生人：霉霉离我就10米
Stranger: Taylor Swift was just 10 meters away from me
陌生人：要是在中国我肯定冲上摸了
Stranger: If it was in China, I would've definitely rushed up to touch her
陌生人：新加坡不太敢
Stranger: But in Singapore, I didn't dare
Shure:  法律比较严格是吧
Shure: The laws are stricter there, right?
Katrina: 这是韭菜饼好像
Katrina: This looks like chive pancakes
Jake: 是吧摸什么
Jake: Right? What are you touching?
陌生人：霉霉离我最近就10米
Stranger: Taylor Swift was just 10 meters away from me
陌生人：因为我冲到第一排了
Stranger: Because I rushed to the front row
Katrina: 那票多少钱
Katrina: How much were the tickets?
Shure:  差一点成功虽然味可能不太一样
Shure: Almost successful, though the taste might be different
Shure:  但是差不多差不多
Shure: But it's close enough
陌生人：票就不要问了有点悲惨的故事
Stranger: Don't ask about the tickets, it's a bit of a tragic story
Jake: 那就更要问了
Jake: Then we definitely need to ask
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 感觉你你也蛮神奇的
Katrina: You seem pretty amazing
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure:  你当多少吃的
Shure: How much did you eat?
Katrina: 你可以去参加那个6句话的故事
Katrina: You can join that six-word story thing
Katrina: 6句话感觉你都说不完呢
Katrina: Six words, you can't even finish it
Shure:  反正吃完12点了
Shure: Anyway, it's already midnight after we finish eating
Katrina: 嘉禾一品
Katrina: Jiahe Yipin
Shure:  还行不是还有其他的
Shure: It's okay, isn't there more?
Katrina: 尝尝嘛
Katrina: Try it
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure:  然后还买少了呢趟
Shure: And I bought too few
Katrina: OK
Katrina: 呃大家要拿碗吗
Katrina: Uh, does everyone need a bowl?
Katrina: 还是什么
Katrina: Or what?
Lucia: 呃都有谁要碗
Lucia: Uh, who needs a bowl?
Lucia: 要碗吗
Lucia: Need a bowl?
Lucia: 可心要碗
Lucia: Does Kexin need a bowl?
Katrina: 我自己有了
Katrina: I got it myself.
Lucia: 我自己都没有
Lucia: I don't even have one myself.
Katrina: 想喝又想喝饮料
Katrina: I want a drink, I really want a drink.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Hmm hmm.
Lucia: 不是这这
Lucia: No, this...
Lucia: 这抹布比碗还油
Lucia: This cloth is oilier than the bowl.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure:  行完完完再说
Shure: Okay, finish it and we'll talk.
Shure:  不着急不着急
Shure: No rush, no rush.
Alice:你那个是什么材质
Alice: What's that material?
Alice: 呃下边那个
Alice: Uh, the one at the bottom.
Alice: 这是一串的
Alice: It's a whole string.
Katrina: 今天是第几天
Katrina: What day is it today?
Katrina: 第4天了
Katrina: It's the 4th day.
Katrina: 笑一下那个老鼠
Katrina: Smile like that mouse.
Alice: 像虎精又不太像虎
Alice: It looks like a tiger spirit, but not quite like a tiger.
Jake: 开吃
Jake: Let's eat.
Jake: 缺人是吧
Jake: Missing someone, right?
Lucia: 我来了坐这边
Lucia: I'm here, I'll sit over here.
Lucia: 呃
Lucia: Uh.
Lucia: 那你走吧
Lucia: Then you can leave.
Katrina: 那你走吧碗就不动了哈哈
Katrina: Then you can leave, the bowl won't move, haha.
Jake: 好哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, hahaha.
Katrina: 那你走吧我碗是死的
Katrina: Then you can leave, my bowl is dead.
Katrina: 那你走吧你是活的
Katrina: Then you can leave, you're alive.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 我们也可以让碗活起来
Jake: We can make the bowl come alive too.
Jake: 全是青草全是草
Jake: It's all grass, all grass.
Jake: 一桌子草
Jake: A whole table of grass.
Jake: 每桌都对
Jake: Every table, right.
其他人：全是素馅
Others: It's all vegetarian filling.
Jake: 哈哈知道为什么吗
Jake: Haha, do you know why?
Jake: 就今天是一个节气
Jake: Because today is a solar term.
Jake: 嗯你怎么知道的
Jake: Hmm, how did you know?
其他人：我查的公众号
Others: I checked a public account.
其他人：但是我不知道
Others: But I don't know.
其他人：谷雨是干嘛谷屁
Others: What does Grain Rain do, grain fart?
Jake: 谷雨是干嘛的
Jake: What's Gu Yu for?
Jake: 谷雨是种种地
Jake: Gu Yu is for planting crops.
Jake: 嗯要下雨了
Jake: Hmm, it's going to rain.
Katrina: 嗯不知道你这买的都是什么
Katrina: Hmm, I don't know what you bought.
Katrina: 线都是一样的吗
Katrina: Are all the wires the same?
Alice: 那是清明前后
Alice: That's around Qingming Festival.
Alice: 种瓜点豆
Alice: Plant melons and beans.
Jake: 哦种东西
Jake: Oh, planting stuff.
其他人：所以谷雨就要吃菜
Others: So you have to eat vegetables during Gu Yu.
Jake:这大概是有一批菜初长
Jake: This is probably when a batch of vegetables first grow.
Alice: 春菜
Alice: Spring vegetables.
Jake: 长完了可以吃了应该
Jake: Once they're grown, you can eat them, I guess.
Alice: 嗯主要是香椿
Alice: Hmm, mainly Xiangchun.
Alice: 香椿在谷雨之后就木质了
Alice: After Gu Yu, Xiangchun becomes woody.
其他人：你们还在录吗
Others: Are you still recording?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 这什么馅的
Jake: What's the filling?
Katrina: 不知道啊
Katrina: I don't know.
Jake: 他有两种馅
Jake: There are two kinds of fillings.
Alice: 韭菜鸡蛋
Alice: Chive and egg.
Jake: 韭菜鸡蛋和肉
Jake: Chive and egg and meat.
Katrina: 我这有肉的
Katrina: I've got the meat one.
Jake: 什么芹菜
Jake: What about celery?
Katrina: 把醋倒这
Katrina: Pour the vinegar here.
Jake: 要醋有芹菜吗这里面
Jake: Do you need vinegar for the celery in here?
Katrina: 没吃的
Katrina: Nothing to eat.
Jake: 还是白菜啊
Jake: Or is it cabbage?
Katrina: 所以那衣服是去租还是买
Katrina: So, are we renting or buying those clothes?
Katrina: 嗯给个预算然后我们办事
Katrina: Hmm, give us a budget and we'll handle it.
Lucia: 要我给你出可行性研究报告吗
Lucia: Do you want me to write a feasibility report for you?
Jake: 好哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, hahaha.
Lucia: 给个预算然后我研究研究
Lucia: Give me a budget and I'll look into it.
Jake: 我我我估一下
Jake: I'll make an estimate.
Jake: 我算一算现在是什么
Jake: Let me calculate what it is now.
Jake: 如果是买的话最便宜是多少
Jake: If we buy, what's the cheapest price?
Tasha: 40是买的上衣
Tasha: 40 for a top.
Tasha: 算了吧我现在看到了有一个
Tasha: Never mind, I see one that's 25 for a whole set.
Tasha: 全部都是25元的一套
Tasha: All of them are 25 yuan per set.
Jake: 什么东西啊25块钱
Jake: What? 25 yuan?
Katrina: 我要去搞一杯北冰洋
Katrina: I'm going to get a Beibingyang soda.
Tasha: 你要来看吗
Tasha: Do you want to come and see?
Jake: 没事
Jake: It's fine.
Tasha: 你看18啊
Tasha: You're looking at 18, right?
Tasha: 三天
Tasha: Three days.
Jake: 好好好这个预算可以
Jake: Okay, okay, this budget works.
Jake: 这个远远没到预算
Jake: This is way under budget.
Jake: 哈哈其实我也不知道预算多少
Jake: Haha, actually I don't even know what the budget is.
Jake: 但是那1,000的话肯定过分了
Jake: But if it's 1,000, that's definitely too much.
Jake: 500以上肯定多
Jake: Anything over 500 is too much.
Katrina: 确实只穿一次
Katrina: Yeah, you'll only wear it once.
Tasha: 但是这个的话就是在长沙
Tasha: But this one is in Changsha.
Tasha: 他要租的话可能就要三天起
Tasha: If you rent it, it might be at least three days.
Tasha: 就只有这一套
Tasha: There's only this one set.
Tasha: 他是18
Tasha: It's 18.
Tasha: 还有这种
Tasha: And there's this kind too.
Tasha: 他好像都是40吧
Tasha: I think they're all around 40, right?
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 这一套
Tasha: This set.
Tasha: 是吧一套两套
Tasha: Right, one set, two sets.
Tasha: 但是如果是这家店的话他就在通州嘛
Tasha: But if it's this shop, it's in Tongzhou.
Tasha: 嗯但他们家好像比较贵
Tasha: Yeah, but their stuff is pretty expensive.
Tasha: 他说点购买就可以知道了
Tasha: They said you can know the price if you purchase it.
Tasha: 第一套是25块钱
Tasha: The first set is 25 yuan.
Tasha: 第二套就要2550358045403520
Tasha: The second set is 2550358045403520.
Lucia: 你们现在用的是
Lucia: What are you guys using now?
Lucia: 那个黄色的那个小软件吗
Lucia: That little yellow app?
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 嗯咸鱼嗯
Lucia: Hm, Xianyu, huh?
Katrina: 咸鱼是个好东西
Katrina: Xianyu is pretty good.
Jake: 一人50左右吧行吧
Jake: Around 50 per person, okay?
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Jake: 可可行吗
Jake: Is it doable?
Lucia: 可行应该是可行
Lucia: Yeah, it should be doable.
Katrina: 可以啊但是租哈利波特衣服
Katrina: Sure, but renting a Harry Potter costume...
Katrina: 一天都只要50块钱
Katrina: It's only 50 yuan a day.
Lucia: 但是我最好是能
Lucia: But it's best if we can...
Lucia: 我们能在附近找到一个实体店租哦
Lucia: If we can find a local store nearby to rent from.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 因为寄过来的话有一个稍微有点慢
Lucia: Because shipping over might be a bit slow.
Tasha: 但是那个的话还挺
Tasha: But that one is actually quite...
Jake: 没亮
Jake: It's not on.
Tasha: 对挺远的
Tasha: Yeah, it's pretty far.
Tasha: 然后25块钱一套
Tasha: And it's 25 bucks for a set.
Tasha: 那一家他居然连鞋子都配
Tasha: That shop even includes shoes.
Tasha: 配饰也都配
Tasha: And accessories too.
Katrina: 这么专业
Katrina: So professional.
Shure:  每次谢运中一来就
Shure: Every time Xie Yunzhong comes,
Shure:  咱们就开始练团是吧
Shure: we start rehearsing, right?
Jake: 对哈哈哈
Jake: Yes, hahaha.
其他人：我这时间来到太不巧了
Others: My timing is just too unlucky.
Jake: 哈哈哈我有筷子
Jake: Hahaha, I have chopsticks.
Katrina: 没有餐具了吗
Katrina: No utensils left?
Jake: 给俩勺子可以
Jake: Two spoons should be fine.
Shure:  别别别别
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  咱又不是没筷子
Shure: We have chopsticks.
Alice: 那个柜子里好多筷子
Alice: There are lots of chopsticks in the cabinet.
Katrina: 这有吧
Katrina: Here, right?
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey,
Shure:  给我倒一点
Shure: Pour me a bit.
Shure:  谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Alice: 这是芹菜叶吗
Alice: Are these celery leaves?
Shure:  我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Katrina: 香椿吧
Katrina: Maybe it's Chinese toon?
Shure:  香椿
Shure: Chinese toon.
Alice: 这个
Alice: This one.
Alice: 这不是香椿吧
Alice: This isn't Chinese toon, right?
Alice: 我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Alice: 不像香椿
Alice: Doesn't look like Chinese toon.
Tasha: 我们都有这么多鸡蛋了
Tasha: We already have so many eggs.
Tasha: 还要买个打鸡蛋吗
Tasha: Do we still need an egg beater?
Lucia: 就是只要我在家就敢吃炒蛋哈哈
Lucia: As long as I'm home, I dare to eat scrambled eggs, haha.
Lucia: 笑话好冷
Lucia: That joke was so lame.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 不是真不是我要逼迫大家吃的
Lucia: No, really, I'm not forcing everyone to eat.
Lucia: 不是这些不是我点的
Lucia: These aren't what I ordered.
Lucia: 不要误会
Lucia: Don't misunderstand.
Lucia: 哎这啥情况
Lucia: Hey, what's going on?
Lucia: 我VPN又掉线了
Lucia: My WeChat disconnected again.
Jake: 又掉线了
Jake: Disconnected again?
Jake: 对好吧
Jake: Alright, fine.
Jake: 那就再连上吧
Jake: Then let's reconnect.
Lucia: 但他应该有电
Lucia: But it should have power.
Lucia: 那为啥
Lucia: Then why...
Alice: 杨老板这个是芹菜叶吗
Alice: Jake, are these celery leaves?
Jake: 呃我看一下菜单
Jake: Uh, let me check the menu.
Lucia: 新建一个
Lucia: Create a new one.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 今天是试做
Lucia: Today is a trial.
Jake: 呃这应该就是香椿苗炒鸡蛋
Jake: Uh, this should be Chinese toon sprouts fried with eggs.
Alice: 这个是香椿苗
Alice: These are Chinese toon sprouts.
Jake: 那就是叫它叫老味道蒸菜
Jake: Then let's call it "Old Flavor Steamed Vegetables."
Jake: 我不知道是什么
Jake: I don't know what it is.
Jake: 我看一下啊
Jake: Let me check.
Jake: 蒿子杆
Jake: Mugwort stems.
Lucia: 这他是锅贴吗
Lucia: Is this a potsticker?
Shure:  差不多吧
Shure: Pretty much.
其他人：我一直以为正宗的叫果子啊
Others: I always thought the authentic name was "Guozi."
Alice: 哦下面还有层嗯
Alice: Oh, there's another layer underneath.
其他人：好像还有一层啊
Others: It seems like there's another layer.
Lucia: 哦这种东西叫锅贴
Lucia: Oh, this thing is called a potsticker.
Lucia: 那这个是什么
Lucia: Then what is this?
Lucia: 尝一下
Lucia: Try it.
其他人：像三河肉饼
Others: It looks like Sanhe meat pie.
Alice: 为什么没有人吃腊八蒜
Alice: Why is no one eating Laba garlic?
Shure:  我吃糖蒜
Shure: I eat sweet garlic.
Shure:  但不吃腊八蒜
Shure: But not Laba garlic.
Alice: 为啥
Alice: Why?
他为什么会变成绿色
Alice: Why does it turn green?
Shure:  因为就是他是坏掉的
Shure: Because it's spoiled.
少忽悠我哈哈哈
Stop kidding me, hahaha.
Shure:  不是腊八蒜
Shure: No, it's Laba garlic.
其他人：糖蒜是白的是吧
Others: Sweet garlic is white, right?
Alice: 腊八蒜
Alice: Laba garlic.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 糖蒜有皮
Alice: Sweet garlic has skin.
Jake: 那是什么蒜
Jake: Then what kind of garlic is it?
Jake: 腊八蒜
Jake: Laba garlic.
Shure:  腊八蒜他这个是就是熟的蒜
Shure: Laba garlic is cooked garlic.
Shure:  那个糖弄糖蒜的时候是那种新鲜的蒜
Shure: When making sweet garlic, you use fresh garlic.
Shure:  就是那种
Shure: It's like...
Shure:  没没没烘过的那种蒜
Shure: The kind of garlic that hasn't been roasted.
Lucia: 看起来像一个饼
Lucia: Looks like a pancake.
Jake: 早餐10块
Jake: Breakfast for 10 bucks.
Jake: 饼
Jake: Pancake.
Jake: 撕了吧
Jake: Tear it up.
Jake: 就在这撕了吧
Jake: Just tear it up here.
Katrina: 知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Jake: 就在这撕掉
Jake: Just tear it up here.
Jake: 看看怎么撕
Jake: Let's see how to tear it.
Shure:  撕什么
Shure: Tear what?
Katrina: 四饼
Katrina: Four pancakes.
Katrina: 挺好
Katrina: Pretty good.
Lucia: 这也是香椿的吗
Lucia: Is this also made from toon leaves?
Alice: 这个是茴香的啊
Alice: This one is made from fennel.
Jake: 撕完了哎
Jake: Done tearing it.
Jake: 没撕完还有一个
Jake: Not done yet, there's one more.
Jake: 自行认领
Jake: Help yourself.
吃两个就吃饱了
Eat two and you'll be full.
Jake: 你说8个
Jake: You said eight.
Katrina: 今天早上吃多了面包
Katrina: Ate too much bread this morning.
Katrina: 今天早上自己做面包
Katrina: Made bread myself this morning.
Katrina: 烤面包大厨在你旁边
Katrina: The bread-baking chef is right next to you.
Tasha: 不知道什么东西
Tasha: Don't know what it is.
Katrina: 黄油面包
Katrina: Butter bread.
Shure:  虽然不是我烤的吧
Shure: Even though I didn't bake it.
Shure:  你应该感到很悲伤吧
Shure: You should feel very sad, right?
其他人：昨天晚上太晚了
Others: It was too late last night.
Katrina: 呵呵呵
Katrina: Hehehe.
Jake: 我们几点考完来着
Jake: What time did we finish baking?
Jake: 9点半10点半
Jake: 9:30 or 10:30?
Katrina: 11点多 10点半跑完
Katrina: A little past 11. Finished running at 10:30.
Alice: 10点半
Alice: 10:30.
Shure: 都12点了
Shure: It was already 12.
Alice:快12点了
Alice: Almost 12.
Jake: 肯定烤上
Jake: Definitely baked.
Jake: 什么时候烤上呢
Jake: When did we start baking?
Jake: 还不知道
Jake: Still don't know.
Katrina: 搞碳呢搞了半天
Katrina: Messing with the charcoal for so long.
Katrina: 我看看拍照的时间就知道
Katrina: Let me check the photo time to know.
Alice: 每根头发丝都裹裹满了
Alice: Every strand of hair is covered.
Alice: 那个烟的味道
Alice: That smoke smell.
Katrina: 嗯所以必须要洗澡洗头
Katrina: Yeah, so you have to take a shower and wash your hair.
Shure:  昨天晚上我还倒头就睡了
Shure: Last night I just fell asleep right away.
Shure:  我靠昨天晚上
Shure: Damn, last night...
Katrina: 9点半吃上第一个串
Katrina: Had my first skewer at 9:30.
Shure:  躺那躺一会
Shure: Lay down for a bit.
Shure:  然后就着了
Shure: Then I fell asleep.
其他人：结果我那那一天朋友还回去
Others: Then my friend went back that day.
其他人：我准备两点钟躺一会
Others: I planned to lay down at 2 o'clock.
其他人：躺到三点开个关
Others: Lay down until 3 to turn it on.
其他人：然后躺到了啥
Others: Then lay down until what?
Jake: 谁赢了
Jake: Who won?
其他人：嗯打平了
Others: It was a tie.
其他人：最后点球皇马赢了
Others: In the end, Real Madrid won on penalties.
其他人：还好我没看
Others: Good thing I didn't watch.
Jake: 是吧你
Jake: Right, you...
Jake: 你是曼城球迷
Jake: You're a Man City fan.
Jake: 哈兰德
Jake: Haaland.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  曼彻斯特
Shure: Manchester.
其他人：所以我是奴巴佩的球迷我很期待奴巴佩打皇马
Others: So I'm a fan of Mbappe, I'm really looking forward to Mbappe playing against Real Madrid.
其他人：因为奴巴佩马上要去皇马了
Others: Because Mbappe is about to join Real Madrid.
Lucia: 他真的要去皇马了吗
Lucia: Is he really going to Real Madrid?
其他人：差不多
Others: Pretty much.
Jake: 打巴黎赢了吗
Jake: Did they beat PSG?
Jake: 就是要打皇马
Jake: They have to play Real Madrid.
其他人：那马上还要打多特
Others: Then they have to play Dortmund.
其他人：然后皇马打多特蒙德
Others: Then Real Madrid will play Dortmund.
Jake: 我以前都不知道
Jake: I didn't know before.
Jake: 达瓦尼自从我做这个和这个
Jake: Since I started doing this and that...
Jake: 啊就这个是我们
Jake: Ah, this is ours...
Jake: 我2022年的一篇paper
Jake: My 2022 paper.
Jake: 他态度比较
Jake: His attitude is more...
Jake: 这个叫叫panelbig
Jake: This is called panelbig.
其他人：确实我当时一看就是大巴黎
Others: Indeed, when I first saw it, it was PSG.
Jake: 对就是这个
Jake: Yes, that's it.
Jake: 是80年代TSG
Jake: It's the 80s TSG.
Jake: 就是大巴黎的那个logo
Jake: It's PSG's logo.
Jake: 嗯然后我们稍微改造改造
Jake: Yeah, then we modified it a bit.
Jake: 改成了我们这个分割的
Jake: Changed to our segmentation
Jake: 就它是一个情景分割
Jake: It's a scene segmentation
Katrina: 呀快递到了
Katrina: Ah, the delivery is here
Jake: 嗯一看是青年分支
Jake: Hmm, it's from the youth branch
Jake: 就就就割出来的这个东西
Jake: It's just the stuff we segmented out
Shure:  所以这个跟大巴黎是真的有关系是吗
Shure: So this is really related to Paris Saint-Germain?
Jake: 简称是就是PSG啊
Jake: The abbreviation is PSG, yeah
Jake: 就硬凑一个简称
Jake: Just forced a shortcut
Shure:  就是正好这个简称是一样的是吗
Shure: So the abbreviation just happens to be the same, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Jake: 就是先出了这个名字
Jake: We came up with the name first
Jake: 然后简称PSG
Jake: Then the shortcut PSG
Jake: 然后我上网一搜
Jake: Then I searched online
Jake: 我靠是个球队
Jake: Damn, it's a team
Jake: 哈哈我才知道
Jake: Haha, that's when I knew
Lucia: 巴黎圣日耳曼
Lucia: Paris Saint-Germain
Shure:  大巴黎他不止有球队
Shure: Paris has not just the team
Shure:  还有那个电竞的队伍嗯
Shure: They also have an esports team, right
Shure:  吃困了
Shure: I'm sleepy
Shure:  吃完就想睡
Shure: Feel like sleeping after eating
Shure:  睡醒了就饿
Shure: Hungry when I wake up
Shure:  饿完就想吃
Shure: Hungry then want to eat
Shure:  感觉人生已经
Shure: Feels like life is
Jake: 对这才是生活
Jake: Yeah, that's life
Jake: 一个life就应该这个样子
Jake: Life should be like this
Jake: 跟里面夹了很多戏
Jake: Added a lot of drama in it
Jake: 太那个了
Jake: It's too much
Shure:  不真实我们
Shure: Not realistic
Shure:  明天床上躺一天啊
Shure: Let's lie in bed all day tomorrow
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah
Shure:  像只蛆一样的蠕动
Shure: Wiggle like a maggot
其他人：我在床上躺一天
Others: I'll lie in bed all day
其他人： 你应该给我300
Others: You should pay me 300
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：可以不
Others: Can you?
Shure:  我靠我让你看我在床上躺着
Shure: Damn, I'll let you watch me lying in bed
其他人：你都是看天花板
Others: You're just staring at the ceiling
其他人：我又看不到你躺着
Others: I can't even see you lying
Shure:  那我把眼镜放这块
Shure: Then I'll place my glasses here
Shure:  然后让他拍
Shure: And let him film it
Shure:  我躺着就是让他
Shure: I'm just lying here letting him
Jake: 那为什么会眼镜
Jake: Then why are there glasses
Shure:  人类是一个草履虫
Shure: Humans are like paramecia
Shure:  只能进行简单的生命活动
Shure: They can only perform simple life activities
Lucia: 哈哈哈救命啊
Lucia: Hahaha, help me!
Katrina: 吃和睡
Katrina: Eating and sleeping
Shure:  感觉吃的差不多了
Shure: I feel like I've eaten enough
Shure:  我好饿啵啵
Shure: I'm so hungry, boo-boo
Shure:  呸我好好饱
Shure: Oops, I'm so full
Jake:谢斌竹什么时候答辩
Jake: When is Xie Binzhu's defense?
Jake: 模拟答辩
Jake: The mock defense
Katrina: 这跟导师有关
Katrina: It depends on the advisor
Katrina: 我以为是学院规律
Katrina: I thought it was the academy's rule
Jake: 就学院要求
Jake: It's the academy's requirement
Jake: 但是导师不管
Jake: But the advisor doesn't care
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why?
其他人：因为他前几次从来没看过
Others: Because he never checked the previous ones
其他人： 都是最高的
Others: They were all the highest scores
Lucia: 哇这样的导师哪里找
Lucia: Wow, where can you find such an advisor?
其他人：然后之前
Others: And then before
其他人：我问了一下
Others: I asked
其他人：就我的导师是我老板他
Others: My advisor is my boss
其他人：他带张子成
Others: He mentored Zhang Zicheng
其他人：然后他被名额挂了一个导师
Others: And he got assigned an advisor slot
其他人：嗯我还问那个老板
Others: Hmm, I asked the boss
其他人：我说我要不要加一下他微信啊
Others: Should I add him on WeChat?
其他人：要不要搞
Others: Should I try?
其他人：他说能不烦他尽量别烦他
Others: He said if you can avoid bothering him, don't bother him
Jake: 烦他就扣分
Jake: Bother him and you get points deducted
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  你只要跟我说一句话我就给你扣一分
Shure: If you just say one word to me, I will deduct one point
其他人：所以到现在我没有和他讲过一句话
Others: So up to now, I haven't said a word to him
Katrina: 哈哈太爽了吧
Katrina: Haha, that's so cool
Jake: 准备满分准备满分
Jake: Ready for full marks, ready for full marks
Jake: 准备满分
Jake: Ready for full marks
其他人：他只说过
Others: He only said
其他人：一次最开始给他发的邮件
Others: Once when I first sent him an email
其他人：他回我一切信息
Others: He replied to all my messages
其他人：请不要联系我
Others: Please do not contact me
其他人：联系男老师就行
Others: Just contact the male teacher.
Shure:  男老师是什么东西
Shure: What's a male teacher supposed to be?
其他人：我们最新的地点啊
Others: It's our latest location.
其他人：是20号叫中文名称
Others: It's called the Chinese name on the 20th.
其他人：嗯然后就24号叫PKD
Others: Yeah, and then it's called PKD on the 24th.
Shure:  嗯 24号叫final report
Shure: Yeah, it's called the final report on the 24th.
Shure:  30号
Shure: On the 30th.
Shure:  没有24号
Shure: Not the 24th.
Shure:  就是所有周边材料
Shure: It's all the surrounding materials.
Shure:  加上那个那什么都要交
Shure: Plus everything else that needs to be handed in.
其他人：那个是离开的地点
Others: That's the departure location.
Shure:  那是他什么的弟弟啊
Shure: Who's his brother anyway?
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure:  你drop的写多少了
Shure: How many pages have you written for the drop?
其他人：我drop写19页
Others: I've written 19 pages for the drop.
Jake: 我当年毕设什么初期报告忘交了
Jake: I forgot to submit my initial graduation project report back then.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 对对恶劣伪报扣了10%
Jake: Yeah, they deducted 10% for that serious fake report.
Jake: 最后90
Jake: In the end, I got 90.
Shure:  对最后90
Shure: Yeah, 90 in the end.
其他人：为什么是因为你导师很好
Others: Why? Was it because your advisor was really good?
Shure:  是因为人家做的很牛逼
Shure: It's because he did an amazing job.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Shure:  你这你就是你
Shure: It's just you.
Shure:  这孩子不会说话
Shure: This kid can't talk.
Shure:  领导都把话递到这了
Shure: The leader already gave you a good word.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈哎呦我的
Shure: Hahaha, oh my.
Shure:  妈呀这是为什么
Shure: Oh my, why is this?
Shure:  你们导师好啊
Shure: Your advisor is really good.
Jake: 导师确实
Jake: The advisor really is.
其他人：只有只有好的导师才会照最强的人
Others: Only good advisors will look after the strongest students.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
其他人：一般好的都一抢个空
Others: Generally, the good ones are highly sought after.
其他人：只有能力强才能抢到这种名额
Others: Only the capable ones can get such a spot.
Shure:  别找补了
Shure: Stop making excuses.
Shure:  明年科员都不一定是了
Shure: Next year, you might not even be a clerk.
Shure:  哈哈你快去山东进修两年吧
Shure: Haha, you should go to Shandong for two years of training.
Alice: 哈哈山东
Alice: Haha, Shandong.
Shure:  山东
Shure: Shandong.
其他人：就是分儿有点夸张
Others: The scores are a bit exaggerated.
Shure:  我一多一分我都不要
Shure: I don't even want one more point.
Shure:  他只要给我60就行
Shure: Just give me 60 and I'm good.
Tasha: 为什么要考90分
Tasha: Why aim for 90 points?
Lucia: 他考了90分
Lucia: He got 90 points.
Tasha: 他考了90分
Tasha: He got 90 points.
Lucia: 嗯哦
Lucia: Yeah.
Tasha: 我还以为啊
Tasha: I thought...
Shure:  我说我要60分就行
Shure: I said just give me 60 points.
Shure:  你多一分都是多给我的都没有用
Shure: Even one extra point is useless to me.
其他人：你企战是60吗
Others: Your target score is 60?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  企站是什么
Shure: What's the target score?
Jake: 企业战略我都记得啊
Jake: Corporate strategy, I remember it all.
Shure:  不是应该不是60
Shure: No, it shouldn't be 60.
其他人：我真的60
Others: Mine was really 60.
其他人：我跟你们说
Others: Let me tell you,
其他人：我就是我考试非常想提前交卷嘛
Others: I really wanted to hand in my paper early.
其他人： 然后考试在考试期我实在是真的不会
Others: During the exam, I really didn't know how to do it.
其他人：然后我本来是有时间复习的
Others: I had time to review,
其他人：但那段时间繁华太好长了
Others: but that period was so busy.
其他人：我就一直在看繁华
Others: I kept watching TV shows.
其他人：所以那个真的没复习我在那看哈哈哈
Others: So I really didn't review, I just kept watching, haha.
Shure:  我带他看哈哈哈
Shure: I was watching with him, haha.
其他人：然后考试的时候我三三十多分就
Others: During the exam, I scored around 30 points and handed it in.
其他人：交卷
Others: Submitted.
其他人： 因为我一堂课没跟你差不多作业啊
Others: I didn't do any homework the whole course.
其他人：其实我不知道老师长什么样
Others: Honestly, I don't know what the teacher looks like.
其他人：其实那个体育老师就是我们的老师
Others: Actually, the PE teacher was our teacher.
其他人：但是我不知道
Others: But I didn't know.
其他人：我以为他只是个小小学生
Others: I thought he was just a small kid.
其他人：我就直接小学
Others: I directly thought he was an elementary student.
Lucia: 小学生小学生真是
Lucia: Elementary student, really.
其他人：小学生我就直接
Others: Elementary student, I just...
其他人：     我就直接教了
Others: I just handed it in.
其他人：教了之后还是他跟我说的
Others: After handing it in, he told me.
Shure:  老师在这阴阳怪气的
Shure: The teacher was being sarcastic.
Shure:  我拿他卷跟你讲啊
Shure: I took his paper and told him.
Shure:  就这种这么早交卷的
Shure: Those who hand in their papers so early,
Shure:  一字不写的
Shure: without writing a single word,
Shure:  不是不是不是没写几个字的
Shure: I mean, barely writing anything,
Shure:  这肯肯定过不了
Shure: there's no way they'll pass.
Shure:  那肯必须挂他
Shure: They definitely have to fail.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那最后没挂呀
Lucia: But they didn't fail in the end.
其他人：只能说老师人太好
Others: Guess the teacher was just too kind.
其他人：可能看我写的屁话太多了不是
Others: Maybe they thought I wrote too much nonsense.
Shure:  不不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  然后他他他说完这番话我就添两个字
Shure: So after he said that, I just added two words.
Shure:  我就咔就笑了哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: And then I just laughed, hahaha.
其他人：把这个噩耗传给我
Others: Spread this bad news to me.
Shure:  对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  我就想想赶紧告诉他这个好消息
Shure: I just wanted to quickly tell him the good news.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：然后我整个寒假生没过好
Others: And my whole winter break was a mess.
Shure:  我们两个
Shure: The two of us...
Katrina: 我感觉我们两个傻逼
Katrina: I feel like the two of us are idiots.
Jake: 学了一寒假企战
Jake: Studied corporate warfare the whole break.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Just...
Lucia: 学是学不了一点
Lucia: I can't learn anything at all.
Jake: 哈哈哈单身可以
Jake: Hahaha, staying single is fine.
Shure:  他妈的
Shure: Damn it.
Shure:  我还有一门课
Shure: I still have one more class.
Shure:  因为平时有一次测测验没去
Shure: Because I missed a quiz once.
Shure:  就是平时小测
Shure: It was just a small quiz.
Shure:  然后我因为那天那个实习有有事
Shure: And I had something going on that day because of my internship.
Shure:  然后我就问那老师
Shure: So I asked the teacher.
Shure:  我说平时分
Shure: I said, my usual score...
Shure:  咱那个没过
Shure: I didn't pass it.
Shure:  但是我总成绩过了能不能给我过
Shure: But my overall score passed, can you let me pass?
Shure:  他说可以的
Shure: He said, sure.
Shure:  然后结果最后给我挂了
Shure:  然后让我重新补了一遍
Shure: So I had to retake it.
Shure:  平时小册
Shure: Usually, it's just a small booklet.
Shure:  唉就特别的耻辱
Shure: Ugh, it was so humiliating.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Katrina: 有两门吗
Katrina: Are there two subjects?
其他人：有有一门平时不错
Other people: There's one that's usually good.
其他人：有一门平时不行
Other people: There's one that's usually not good.
Shure:  唉我不知道
Shure: Sigh, I don't know.
Shure:  反正他不是他自己亲口说的
Shure: Anyway, it wasn't him who said it himself.
Shure:  然后最后搞这种
Shure: And then, in the end, doing this kind of thing.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Jake: 走吧还眼镜
Jake: Let's go, still need glasses.
Shure:  好disconnect finish
Shure: Okay, disconnect finish.
Shure:  完了我这又没有那个finish那个键
Shure: Oh no, I don't have that finish button again.
Alice: 我也是哦
Alice: Me too.
Alice: 好了
Alice: Done.
Shure:  connecting oh okay
Shure: Connecting... oh, okay.
Shure: complete recording
Shure: Complete recording.